antiguas deudas con las mujeres y
personas trans en España así han sido
calificadas las nuevas leyes aprobadas
por el congreso la ley sobre el aborto
elimina el requisito de autorización de
los padres para jóvenes de 16 y 17 años
yo creo que aquí hay una cuestión muy
importante en primer lugar en relación
al aborto está claro que si yo con 16
años Soy lo suficientemente madura y
adulta como para atraer al mundo a una
criatura y sacarla adelante con todo lo
que implica al menos las personas que
hemos sido madres o padres Yo creo que
por lo tanto también tengo la capacidad
de tomar una decisión tan importante
como de no tener esa criatura las
mujeres y personas con capacidad para
gestar mayores de 16 años podrán abortar
libremente hasta las 14 semanas de
gestación hasta las 22 por riesgo para
la vida o la salud de la madre o
anomalías graves del feto y en Casos
excepcionales después de esa fecha la
norma además elimina la obligación de
informar a los gestantes sobre opciones
alternas al aborto y sobre el plazo de
reflexión de tres días sobre la
interrupción del embarazo la ley para la
igualdad y efectiva de las personas
trans y para la garantía de los derechos
de las personas lgtbi también conocida
como ley trans garantiza la
autodeterminación de género y establece
los 16 años como único requisito para el
cambio legal de sexo elimina la
hormonación hasta ahora obligatoria y
Las evaluaciones psicológicas y médicas
los menores de entre 14 y 16 años
tendrán que realizar el trámite con sus
padres o tutores al tiempo que los
menores entre 12 y 14 requieren
autorización judicial
hoy la libertad o la diversidad hoy el
respeto gana a la intolerancia gana al
odio y gana los bulos hoy España es
mejor país para todas no solamente para
las personas además se adoptó una medida
pionera en Europa y es la baja por
menstruación incapacitante asociada a
patologías como la endometriosis